Let me show you all the shit I got from target last night.
Favorite bag to go grocery shopping with.
And I know I look silly, but I can put all my heavy shit in there. Okay.
I overloaded my hair with protein.
You know how it used to be like super curly and bouncy?
It's like dead.
I didn't realize that the leave in conditioner I had had protein in it.
And so now I need to like,
clarify my hair. I need to like,
try to get any excess protein off
and I need to deep condition it.
I also think my scalp is really dry,
so I had to get deep scalp hydration.
But also head and shoulders.
Hope it works. This shit,
I used to use the Pacifica Pineapple Curls Curl Cream.
I just think it's too heavy of a product for my hair and my curl type.
I have very, like a very fine hair.
And since I'm getting a lot of gray,
it's also like the texture is changing.
So I think the curl cream is too much.
I think I just need mousse.
So I got their conditioner,
cause I just really like their shit.
And it smells so good and it's really,
really good shit. You know that little spot in target
where you can get three little things?
Oh, I got dry shampoo
cause one of my daughters has a very oily scalp.
Like, you wash her hair and like the Next day,
it's like, grease bomb.
I think her hair gets washed too often.
I'm not sure, but we're gonna go dry shampoo.
Oh, I got a setting spray because they're fucking, um.
Primer is the stickiest shit on the planet.
So I figure with the primer,
makeup, and then the setting spray,
hopefully my makeup will be good,
because I was recently filmed on an episode of Middle Ground.
Oh, I also got an eye eyelid primer,
because my eyelids are super fucking hooded.
Like, you know,
go away. They, like,
fold a bunch. So if I try to do makeup,
I get really hard creases. I got eyelid primer.
My boyfriend bought toothpaste.
Not for me. Somebody sent me a message the other day,
and they were like, I like you,
but I'm gonna stop following you because your shit,
to me, is not accurate.
You're not like a single mom.
You have help.
You have somebody that's gonna wake up in the middle of the night
when one of your kids are sick
and help you. You have somebody that was gonna split bills with you.
He's gonna help pay expenses for your kids.
And I was like, I appreciate the kindness, and, like,
no hate to you, and you are completely mistaken.
That month, we are roommates for all intents and purposes.
Do you know what I mean? He's not a stepdad.
He doesn't help me with motherfucking.
He's a boyfriend. He does boyfriend. Shit.
But, you know,
and it's shitty
because when I lived with a woman and a woman was helping me,
I mean, she was cooking dinner,
serving my children and then tucking them into bed for me.
She was cleaning up vomit after they puked.
Nobody was like, oh,
you're not a single mom. They were like, oh,
two single moms, two single mom moms,
you know what I mean? Or like,
you're gonna tell me
if somebody's grandma and grandpa help babysit the kids,
now they're not a single mom
just cause you have like an ounce of help,
now you're no longer a single mom.
No, you're just looking for a way to tear women apart
based on an insecurity that you have.
And I'm not here for that.
So I don't know what the fuck it is,
but it was cute and it was square
and it's a moisturizing gel cream, so.
And it was in that little spot in target.
So then I also got more shit for my hair,
because since I have a lot of fucking gray,
I got a purple shampoo, cause I read online,
but I only wanted to get a little one.
And I've heard this conditioner is really good.
Camille Rose.
I just wanna make sure it doesn't fucking have protein in it.
But um, I've heard if you wash your gray hair with purple,
it can like tone it down. Cause my gray is very silver,
it's very sparkly. I wanna, like.
Can we just.
Just, like.
I don't know.
I don't know. I got another deep conditioner
because that's something else you have to do after too much protein.
My boyfriend bought this, not me.
We have different budgets.
I bought this boy bio oil shit
because I realize I have a ton of melasma.
That's why it looks like I have a mustache.
I don't. That's just some damage.
There's no hair.
So I bought this. I don't know if it works,
but it was in that target spot.
This was. These were all in that. Okay, okay.
Did buy enough. It was a buy three get one free.
And I was like, damn it.
I don't think I bought three.
I think I bought. I think I.
I think I bought three and didn't get a fourth for free.
You know what, though?
I did buy three and not a goddamn one of them was free.
I was right. My. Okay. Okay.
I am right. I'm pretty sure I threw my receipt away.
Yeah, that's not my receipt.
I got wrinkle off cause I'm gonna be in LA soon.
Oh, and I got more of that tart.
The Fucking Tarte tubing mascara and the fake awake are legit.
I would have bought them from the TikTok shop,
but I needed them, like,
now cause I'm traveling soon.
I didn't have time to wait for them to be shipped when I got this shit.
I think I'm Probably gonna give it to my daughter, though.
She really wanted it for her birthday.
Actually, I'm probably.
I don't know. She probably gets.
I don't fucking know. Anyway, happy Saturday.